[Music]
my voice is a little bit off today goes
barcelona won last night and it was a
bit stressful what I'm going to present
today is joint work by a bunch of people
whose faces and names you can find here
which is effectively the data science
team at let book so you may be asking
yourself what is let go and what we're
gonna go through today so first I'm
going to introduce you to the problem of
listing categorization and then we'll go
through the process we more or less
followed to solve that problem which was
building a categorization dataset
building a taxonomy starting with an
image spaced distinct at organization
system and then I'll tell you a little
bit about what we're planning to do next
so let go is a Sun dimension are quite a
big local two sided market place to
exchange use goods where sellers sell
and buyers buy we're very big in the US
and Turkey but most of the our
engineering team is here in Barcelona
Spain so the problem we try to solve is
the following me are now I live in
Hoboken New York and I have this a road
bag that I want to get rid of and then
Luca my teammate lives in Jersey City
also New York and has been thinking
about getting a bike for some time so
what I do is that I post my back into
our platform and Luca searches for a
bike in our platform and the platform
allows us to meet an exchange in this
case this this bicycle very simple now
one of the key elements of any use goods
market place is correct categorization
of the catalog right so when a user a
seller in this case me posts a bike
there's a number of steps that happen
before that listing we call the products
in our platform listings goes into our
listing catalog one of these processes
moderation so making sure that the
content is appropriate another one of
the process
categorization so making that by
categorizing that listing into one of
the many categories that our buyers
search for once the listing is in the
catalog then it gets exposed to our
buyers through recommender system search
filter related listings etc so why are
we trying to solve that problem using
fancy data science as opposed to just
asking the sellers during posting time
what's the category of your item well
there in fact the reasons the first one
is that if you've worked on
internet-based applications or pretty
much any other software product you will
know that as you increase the friction
in any process there's a number of users
that drop from that process this is not
actual data but is something that we
know from every experiment as you start
asking for more details user stopped
completing the process and this is
something that we want to avoid because
we want to have as many listings as
possible on the other hand there's
another problem which is that if you ask
sellers they may not give you the
appropriate category one of the reasons
they may not do so is because they are
adversarial for instance so they are
trying to in this case buy iPhones and
in order to get as much exposure to
their listing which is a service I apply
iPhones
they may place it in the iPhone category
okay another reason is that categories
are sometimes complex and it's not clear
to the sellers where they should
categorize their item right so here for
instance I I posted a listing that was
categorized as a car when in fact it's a
it's a car part this is an engine so
whether what's the problem we're trying
to solve it's very simply stated we have
a listing that gets posted by a seller
in this case this is a twin root
stroller the listing comprises a number
of images a title a description price
and perhaps some other metadata and then
we want to build a system a listing
categorize er that takes this
information as an input and outputs the
category that this listing should be
assigned to okay so many of you in the
audience may be thinking this is just
classical supervised learning setup
okay easy why am I talking about this
well it turns out that it's not a simple
problem at all in fact there are many
challenges the first one um and this is
not by order of importance but by order
of my thinking is the challenge of
ambiguity right so sometimes users they
will post a listing like this one
without much information in in the form
of title or description now if you just
see this image there's no way for you
for a human or machine or whatever to
decide whether this is someone selling a
TV a TV stand or the TV and the TV stand
the bundle okay so these ambiguous
situations are quite common another
problem is that our data is quite noisy
because it's user input and it's user
input via a mobile application right
which has the its own
caveat so for instance here I'm showing
an example of a cardigan right I mean
depending on your monitor you may be
able to identify a cardigan or not
because the image is quite quite bad
quality another interesting problem is
what we call and some people in the
Academy called the open world problem
which is that categories of objects
appear and disappear quite regularly so
here I'm showing a specific category
that together with the Google trend on
top which was fidget spinners so feature
spinners anyone familiar with what
fitted spinner is okay I discovered them
when it's like what is this thing people
are looking for so they became very
popular a couple years ago and you know
everyone was posting them and then at
some point they kind of disappeared okay
so this means that your categories need
to be updated with with the at least
with the man or with with supplied and
then finally as I mentioned earlier
there are adversarial actors right so
there are people that are trying to
cheat your your system for their own
benefit or just because they they want
to have fun so let's start with with the
first step in building a listening
categorization problem which as we saw
earlier is a supervisor
problem and hence requires training data
so when we want to train a model we need
training data and label data is
typically somewhat expensive right so
here I I'm a I did some calculations so
you know if you have if you want to be
able to categorize into the 1500
categories of products and you want to
have a modicum amount of like a thousand
samples per category you need one I 1/2
million samples and then if you do the
math and include some replication factor
to make sure that you correct for the
bias or variance of the annotators
you're talking about like you know about
200k above 200k $200,000 worth of
labeling budget obviously if you go to
your VP of Finance and say hey I have
this wonderful new project you know give
me two hundred K and I'll solve it it
may not be a good strategy so another
strategy is to kind of like bootstrap
your way through the problem which is
exactly what we did by taking advantage
of what we called implicit user feedback
okay and the idea is very simple many
people use it we didn't invent this but
still useful to to most people that that
run a business like ours so when a user
comes to our app and run to search in
this case the search query is a road
bike the app returns hopefully a number
of road bikes if we've done our our
search and relevance work properly and
the user selects one of them the one
that he or she finds interested
interesting and contact them perhaps
views the item then contacts the seller
and then eventually transact ok now
every time this happens if we start
aggregating across different sessions
users etc what we end up having is for a
very large amount of our products our
listings the search queries that people
used to actually contact the sellers
from that listing so for instance in
this case we have this univita
mix Road by
that was contacted by three different
users after searching for the query
roadbike obviously we don't have just
one listing and one query you know we
may have people searching for Cannondale
we have four users that search for
Cannondale and ended up on this listing
we have one user that search for webpack
and ended up on this different listing
now at this point you probably already
understand where i'm going at we have
tens of millions of different search
queries so different strings of text a
month which means and we have I don't
know how many millions of search
sessions a month which means we have an
amazing
profit of trove of data of this of this
type so it is not all rosy in the
implicit user feedback space and there's
a number of challenges and so I wanted
to highlight a few of them the first one
is that you have potential selection
bias what does this mean
so every slide needs to have a vent
every slide deck needs to have a Venn
diagram at least to look smart I guess
so here's my Venn diagram this is the
set of posted listings what we call the
product supply this is the set of demand
that we call we call search queries and
the intersection of those two sets is
the are the listings that have implicit
annotations so the ones that I got
tagged with some search query after the
users interacted with that listing now
obviously if the probability of each
class under this sample schema so the
listings that were posted and also were
contacted by a search query is different
than the probability of the class in the
in the ensemble of products apply then I
may run into into problems because it
may happen that in my training set I
have a lot more talk a lot more more a
lot more often a certain type of
listings then I actually do have in
reality and this may be as my
so that's one problem not necessarily
the most difficult one to address
another problem is what we call
uncorrelated label noise so for some
queries what happens is the following
the user issues the query sub in this
case which in the US refers to
subwoofers 99% of the time and our
algorithm or search algorithm correctly
returns mostly subwoofers but if you
scroll down enough you may end up
finding something that has nothing to do
with the subwoofer and that happens to
pick the interest of the seller ok the
user end up ends up contacting the
submariner action figure when in fact
her intent was to look for subwoofers so
we call this obviously such a such a
contact we'll create an annotation
that's wrong right because that
listening here is not a subwoofer but we
have annotated it according to the user
as such now this error this noise is
uncorrelated because the label error
depends very weakly on the listing
attributes right and we can discuss this
later because it's it's a strong
statement for very weak evidence but my
point is that the source of this type of
label noise of this type of erroneous
annotations is perhaps curiosity
mistakes due to the UX in the app or
other it doesn't have to anything to do
with the listing itself okay
now the good news is that this type of
error is sort of easy to deal with um
through outlier detection not easy but
you can you can sort of work with it and
I'll talk about one way to deal with it
later the most complex type of error is
what we call correlated label noise and
I'm gonna give an example here so here
the user search for Cannondale bike okay
if the user contacts an actual
Cannondale bike afterwards then no
problem right the user contacts this
Cannondale mountain bike here we get an
annotation for that listing we can use
it later no problem now
in those search results if you scroll
down enough we may start showing things
that are related to canon del canon del
bikes but there are not quite canon del
bikes another good strategy for search
because you want people to stay engage
now the problem is that the user is
going to contact this canon date choose
after searching for canon they like and
this is going to create an annotation
that's wrong but it's wrong in a
specific way that's that's a little bit
harder to deal with than the previous
one because in this case the there is a
correlation between that the attributes
of the listing and the noise that are
the error that the the annotation
introduced the seller introduced the
sources of this type of labels are not
the same as before where it was a
mistake or curiosity here it's more
perhaps the two listings were similar
they are from the same domain in this
case those are biking shoes or perhaps
there is a correlation in the user
interest you know a person that's
interested in bikes is probably
interested in biking shoes or perhaps
you just have errors in your catalogue
and there are a systematic and this is
the type of noise that's a lot harder to
do with um and that i'm not actually
going to present anyway to mitigate it
because we're still investigating okay
good news is that none of these issues
is a deal breaker for the job that we're
trying to do which is to build a
categorization data set now we have a
data set we have a plan and what we need
now is a taxonomy okay so what is a
taxonomy a taxonomy is a very simple
concept here we have a chair in a
classified platform in Amazon in any
place that sells chairs there are not
one type of chairs but many okay so here
this is just a sample of the different
type of chairs that we have Adirondack
gaming feeling now in order to
understand the information and to
evaluate the model later we need to
actually start thinking about these
possible classes in a structure that is
easier to understand and so what we can
do is okay
group all these labels into the chair
subcategory in our taxonomy and
similarly we don't only have chairs we
also have our Mars bed bed print words
cabinet - titra which are all part of
furniture ok so what I'm describing here
is one taxonomy of the many taxonomies
that you could decide for your for your
marketplace why do we know this because
in the end the leaves of this taxonomy
here we have a three level taxonomy are
going to be the classes in our
classifier and the tree structure
encodes the relationship between the
labels so if we have to build a taxonomy
we need to have a criteria to decide
what makes a good taxonomy so what does
it make a good taxonomy so two things
mostly the first one is that you want to
have good coverage of both supply and
demand right if you have a very fine
grain sorry if you cover all possible
supply but you're leaving some demand
out you will never be able to figure out
that you need to get some types of
products that you currently don't have
on the other hand you are it also needs
to be user-friendly so one way to
measure how user-friendly it is is to
minimize user confusion while offering
sufficient level of granularity here the
the chart I show is the result of a UX
research experiment which is called card
sorting where you show random users in
focus groups the your category tree and
you evaluate how easy it is for them to
use it through this confusion matrix
type representation so okay we
understand more or less how to how to
evaluate a taxonomy given one but we
still know we still don't know how to
build one from scratch okay now
typically building a taxonomy is a
manual process right I'm sure there's
some papers out there that do it
automatically there in the real world I
think it's mostly an
process and so that process goes as
follows you have a bucket with class
labels with every possible class that
you have been able to imagine and then
you pick one of the possible class
labels here road bike and then you scan
through all the other possible class
labels and you know check with green if
those two class labels are related and
then you create a group of all the class
labels that were related okay in this
case I found road bikes they are
associated with hybrid bikes B and BMX
bikes that's it run so I label all these
labels in their first level of taxonomy
which is called bikes now if you think
of it this is a this is a so if K is the
number of labels in your in your
universe these are a k k square process
right even if it's a human who does it
for each one of the labels we will have
to scan K of the other one so you have
to do this in the order of K square
times which is obviously too
time-consuming if you have 1500 of them
so the question is we don't think we can
actually replace completely that manual
process but can we help speeding it up
so what I'm going to describe next is a
simple strategy to speed up these semi
manual process of creating a taxonomy so
as we as I described in the first
section we have a way to associate
search queries which now are classes
let's just call them different types of
classes in our different types of
categories to listings okay so this
gives me a way to map potential classes
to a vector space of dimension n where n
is the number of listings in in our
platform here n could be in the order of
many hundreds of millions so this is a
massive fat matrix
Farren short now the number of classes
is in the order of several thousands ok
so now we have this encoding of the
classes and we're just going to do our
favorite thing which is to embed this
vector
into a much smaller lower dimensional
space you can use your favorite
embedding algorithm or Tubac
non-negative matrix factorization latent
semantic indexing it doesn't quite
matter we personally we used word two
back because we tried different options
and that was the one that was working
best and we get this matrix that now is
not as fat and short but a little bit
more rectangular so still still fat but
not as fat as before or actually in this
case it would be slimming and tall so we
went from financial to slim and tall
because D the dimension of the embedding
is a lot smaller than the number of
classes so we're almost done there
because now we can just resort to like a
beautiful existing clustering algorithm
in this case a hierarchical clustering
to take all these representations of the
classes map them in a in a way that we
can humanely parse it and that takes us
a lot less time than if we had to
actually scan each one of the classes
against all other okay so there's many
ways to interpret this but one way is
that when you have a dendogram such as
this one you have an ordering of the
labels that has semantic sense and so
instead of having to look one against
all the others you have to look at a
much smaller range all right so we're
getting to to the final step of the
problem which is actually building we
have two data set we have the possible
labels and their relationship to the
economy and now we want to build the
model so again a very reasonable
question to ask is why am I going to
talk about image based listening
categorization and leave out other
possible attributes such as price text
user attribute what-have-you and there
are actually two reasons so the first
one is that at the beginning in order to
create a network effect in our in our
marketplace so having enough supply our
posting process was just requiring an
image you would
an image you're posting would be
processed we would create an automatic
title we would categorize it for you
moderated you didn't have to worry about
anything so very few listings actually
had a description so at that time all we
had to work with was an image and that's
that's the reason why we started working
on image categorization only first the
other reason which is more relevant
currently where we do have data more
data but most of our listings is that
even if you do have more info sometimes
you want to check whether the
information in the text and the image
actually match because it's one way to
detect whether the users are trying to
trick you are classical tricking trick
in marketplaces is for you to post
anything or actually are also in search
engines to post whatever you want to
post and and do like put iPhone because
everyone knows that iPhones are one of
the most thing and more searched for
listings in the platform right so you
take your your backpack that's about to
crumble like mine and you post it as an
iPhone so that people see it even if
they are not actually looking for it
okay so we started with image
categorization and as I mentioned we did
somewhere to define a taxonomy we did
somewhere to generate a data set in a
cost-effective manner then we had to do
some pre-processing because as we saw
there are there were there were some
noise in the labels of our data set and
there's some pre-processing that one
wants to do regardless if there's noise
or not there is some training which we
did with which we use sage maker 4 and
I'll get into more details around this
in a few slides and then there's some
evaluation and debugging on the
performance of of our model which is
first done automatically based on the
noisy on a validation set with the noisy
levels that we obtained from our data
set generation process and secondly
manually and I'll also give a give a bit
more details about what we what we mean
by that where we use sage maker ground
truth and finally this circle this cycle
is closed by us the data scientist
looking at the reports figuring out
what's working what's not and updating
taxonomy that does a generation the
mother what-have-you and iterating over
and over so earlier I mentioned that
uncorrelated level noise can be cleaned
with outlier detection here I just
wanted to share with you a technique
that proved to be quite effective which
is called isolation forests and it's
within invent this I'll put the citation
in a second this is a very simple
technique to detect outliers okay
so what we do is very simple we take all
the samples for one flow for one class
say DSLR cameras and we project them on
in one space let's suppose that that
space is two-dimensional in fact it's
not and so this cloud of of samples some
of them will be surrounded by many other
samples some of them will be like the X
oh they're a lot farther apart from the
rest of the samples
now what isolation forest does is very
simple it says how many trees so how
many how many cuts in a tree do I need
to do in order to uniquely identify each
sample okay so if you see from the the
picture the picture already gives an
intuition that the number of cuts you
need to do the number of partitions you
need to do of your space in order to
uniquely isolate an entire so a regular
sample is a lot bigger than the number
of cuts that you need to do to isolate
the outlier X out there okay so then the
technique Maps
this statistic which is the number of
cuts across several trees in the forest
do something called anomaly score which
tends to be centered around some value
for the inliers
and tends to be away from this from the
mode of this distribution for outliers
so now all you need to do is pick a
threshold and declare outliers as an
outlier anything that's below that
threshold what's cool about it is that
this actually works quite well so here
I'm just giving some aches
of outliers that we detected under the
category DSLR cameras okay so just a
little note here on why this doesn't
work for correlated label noise for
correlated label noise what would happen
is that things that are related to DSLR
cameras like tripods for instance would
probably be also close to the SLR camera
so it will be impossible to distinguish
them and there's a good reason why this
happens the takeaway here is that this
works for things that are really
unrelated to the features that you're
looking at in this case the the things
that look like DSLR camera
so after pre-processing what we need to
do is strain the model and for that we
use the stage maker platform how many
people have used aw Sh maker in the room
okay so since it's not very many of you
I'll just briefly explain what it does I
think it's very very useful so say it's
maker is a way for you to allow you as a
little scientist to focus on stuff
that's not the domain of DevOps as much
as possible
okay so what's its maker requires and
here I'm describing one version of it
there's other versions but this is the
one we're using is one where you define
your training algorithm in one of the
possible compatible frameworks in our
case we use an x net and we also you
also define the environment on which
this training algorithm needs to be
executed in this case the environment is
defined as a docker file or a docker
container that contains all the
dependencies libraries etc that support
the execution of your training script
you also provide an inference script
which does the same for the case when
your model is already trained and you
want to do inference with new images or
rather okay so you provide this together
with a training evaluation data set in
in s3 and you give it to stage maker
and sage maker will run in the
infrastructure that you that you asked
it to run it on and it will produce a
mother artifacts and save them in an
Amazon s3 so I'm not paid by Amazon and
I want to prove it by animating a little
bit the pros and cons of this approach
the pros are that it's actually quite
easy to use and yet very flexible right
so you don't need to marry any of the
existing algorithms if you can develop
and you can develop your own
architecture you can do that if you have
we are doing research and have some
ideas on how to find you and I exist in
that or other you can do it so it's very
flexible in that regard but it's also
very powerful because it provides things
like endpoint auto scaling right so for
instance we have a lot of traffic so our
endpoints our classification endpoints
needs need to handle quite a high number
of requests per second under low latency
requirements in a typical scenario we
would have to worry with devups and
possibly machinery energy and machine
learnings engineer to tune the thing but
sage maker gives you the power to
abstract away abstract yourself away
from that and kind of like use all the
bells and whistles that the AWS
ecosystem provides now on the con side I
want to warn you there are some tricky
things to deal with
first one is the debugging is quite hard
because you know you launch this thing
and it gets X you execute it on a VM
somewhere that you don't really have
access to all you can see is look at the
logs and kind of wonder what's going on
then on the inference side so once
you've trained the model and you're
deploying it as an endpoint it's not
cheap it's quite expensive their sdk has
proven to be quite unstable lately
they've broken our code like a couple
times in just a month and integration
testing is absolutely it's very very
hard right because it's very hard to
replicate exactly the environment on
which your your models either for
training or inference are being executed
so how are we on time
good okay excellent so let's move on now
to the next step in this virtuous circle
cycle that I described earlier taxonomy
we have the data set with pre process we
have train the model and now it's time
to start debugging the model because as
you all know there's no model that works
as is at the first try so for that
typically what we'll do is we'll define
a set of global metrics
you know precision recall accuracy at
the different levels of our taxonomy and
will also define some local metrics to
understand how each class is performing
the insight though which is a little bit
self-evident if you've been in this
business for a while is that metrics are
very good to measure progress so they
give you a good way to understand
whether you're doing better or worse but
they're not as good to want to help you
understand how to fix that
okay of course there are metrics that
help you in that direction but my point
is that most of the times what you have
to do is actually go look at the data
and understand what may be causing the
mistakes that you're seeing so this is
exactly what we do in our reports among
other things we issue our confusion
report and we will find things like this
so these are a set of ten objects that
were labeled as a candle stand but our
model classified as a candle holder now
for 99% of humans these two things are
the same but apparently they are not
okay
so there's some differences on what a
candle stand is and what AI candle
holder is and when you see a problem
like this you may start wondering okay
is it a model capacity problem is it
that my problem doesn't have enough
capacity to actually be able to
distinguish those two classes especially
if you see this type of errors in
training and not just some validation
other types of things you know this is
that okay here I have a bunch of
motorcycle tires that were classified as
a motorcycle helmet oh wait these are
not motorcycle tires these are actually
motorcycle helmets so here's an example
of items that were actually wrong
wrongly labeled
in our validation on training data set
because of the problems I and earlier
and then another common example is that
sometimes there are types of objects
that are just simply undistinguishable
indistinguishable from the image alone
right so which one of those is a chess
board which one of those is a chess set
impossible to know until you actually
look at what the user said she is
selling there's other potential issues
like low sample size you may have very
low sample size for some categories
that's causing increased error on
destroying classes etc takeaway is
looking at the data gives a lot more
information than most metrics one can
think of so all of this evaluation so
far has been done with the noisy labels
the labels that we gathered from the
user implicit feedback now what happens
is that there this has two problems the
first one is that noisy levels means
mean that we can't really trust our
accuracy metrics right so when it tells
us it's 80% accurate it's 80% accurate
relative to a label that may be 90
percent wrong okay so that's a problem
and then the other problem is that we
don't quite care that much about whether
something is absolutely accurately
classified what we care the most about
is whether from a customer per set
perspective that thing is correctly
classified and those two things are
correlated but not necessarily equal so
to circumvent those two issues what we
want to do is we gather human level so
we'll have people actually evaluate our
model which seems super easy right we
take a listing or we take each listing
in our data set we run them through our
model we send it to Amazon sized maker
ground truth which is a labeling service
of Amazon together with our models
prediction and we let people tell us
whether your mother is doing the right
thing or not seems easy well turns out
it's not that easy as everyone
everything in in our data science life
because there's a number of questions
that actually
a matter a lot the first one is what do
exactly ask for the evaluator do we ask
it him or her to tell us is our
annotation is our predicted prediction
right or wrong or do we ask the person
to tell us which one is the correct one
do we show all the imagined in the
listing or do we just sew the image that
most buyers in the site will see which
is the first one do we also show the
text do we give the users some contacts
with the category tree so that they
understand what other possible
categories that are there's many
questions and what happens is that
depending on how you answer them you get
different different evaluation results
here I'm showing the UI that we finally
ended up using that's not important the
important is that you have to think
about it an experiment and you do that
you hit the nail in there in the head
all right so I have five minutes left
and which is great because I'm about to
wrap up so I would just wanted to share
some conclusions on what I've been
talking about the first one is that in
our opinion this implicit feedback way
of generating annotated data set is
quite cost-effective and with problems
that one can handle another point is
that performance evaluation of a model
in in with so many glasses is not
trivial at all and you have to think an
experiment quite a lot to get it right
which means that you also need to be
able to iterate so the days of building
your mother on a two peter notebook and
kind of like versioning by changing the
the suffix in your notebook filename are
over you have to be a little bit smarter
about how to handle versioning and
making sure that you can cycle through
iterations quickly to just keep tuning
all the knobs and then finally I believe
that's H maker and I think Google is a
has something that resembles is not
quite mature yet but also similar tool
is provides quite a good trade-off
between flexibility and ease of use
now as next steps we are already working
about to fix some of the problems and we
have some reason
um in order to resolve some of the
ambiguities when you have such a deep
taxonomy there are things that are very
hard to distinguish and obviously using
all images as opposed to just one and
using text helps helps quite a lot so
we're seeing we're seeing improve
improvement and gains in accuracy of 10
points which is quite significant and
then as far as how to handle the
correlated level noise there's some work
in the literature we can call it noise
aware mother some others that understand
that the labels are not all right
they are quite complex and I think we
think it's it's a nice a nice area of a
little bit more industry research to
explore so with this I wanted to thank
you for your attention on ask for
questions if there's any hi I wanted to
ask maybe you can elaborate a bit more
on what kind of tools you use for where
the bugging of those mistakes how do you
inspect what labels are incorrect and so
on yeah also process so our process is
very simple right now there's no fancy
like looking at what is it called
salience Maps or like trying to
understand what attributes within the
image are the ones that are triggering
the decision so we haven't gotten there
yet because so far most of Rods we had
to solve were already quite evident in
by looking at the regular metrics you
would look at so precision recall perco
per class relationship between sample
size and f1 score for instance to
understand if you're missing sample
somewhere looking at the confusions and
a bunch of like pretty basic things yeah
next step would be also to go a little
bit deeper into understanding why some
models are why some errors are triggered
thank you for your talk and question
about cost out problem what do you do
with just saw some stuff that is not
present in your list yeah I would do is
talk with them yeah that's a very good
literary question we don't really have
an answer
so I think there are ways to detect way
what may be missing by looking at
queries that are nowhere represented in
your in your data set so we end up
having a map from query to category
right so you can look for high-volume
queries that are nowhere in your in your
in this map and these will highlight
things that you may want to add in your
taxonomy
now this solves the problem from the
demand side it doesn't quite solve it
from from the supply side so honestly I
think we have a select them and do some
lingo
there will be some manual work involved
for sure I can't really think of a way
to automate it the question is how much
can you help that manual work you know
can you give some some indication so the
manual work is on a smaller subset of
things than what it would be if you
don't give any any clues hey yeah yeah
um so I'd be interested a bit in what
you actually classify so is it really
just the image or also are you sending
also a bit like the main title or the
text and if there are multiple images
are you basically classifying one by one
and then aggregating the the labels or
combination of this yeah so what I
described here this is things that we
did some time ago
and it this is purely one image based
classification right as you are
suggesting and as I mentioned in the
next steps we already working on
multimodal
which for us means grabbing all the
images grabbing the text price any other
possible feature that may be predictive
of the class for that we've also tried
the variety of things so for aggregating
over several images there's different
ways you could just do like a simple
average you could do some time of tf-idf
transformation on the on the
representation of the listing as a bag
of words of categories there's different
things you can try they all seem to
improve by about the same amount and
then what really makes the difference is
looking at the text because the hardest
problems to resolve are the ones that
there's just no information in the
images to resolve that ambiguity right
so
TV stand TVs are quite good because no
matter what picture you take of a TV and
a TV stand you know it will look like
the same in fact TVs and TV stands they
do have some differences because if
you're selling the TV you know they'll
focus more on the TV and more less on
the TV stand
so there are ways to do this with object
detection and try to understand the
scene more generally etc but if you just
look at the text it's going to solve
your problem a lot faster exactly yeah
yeah yeah hey thanks for the talk have
you praise you that the taxonomy in one
country is different to taxonomy in
other country because of congruent
reasons yes so there are different so we
don't really the separate economies it's
just one taxonomy but some of the
classes don't exist in one of the
countries right for instance in Turkey
there's like there's a couple of
instruments buzz I think is called any
Turkish in the room oh yeah a gherkin
says yeah there's assassin there's
another one that yeah exactly and then
there's a the rosary that thing with uh
there's a there's another category that
I remember very vividly so we have a
meme on taxonomy only that there won't
be any volume for for one of the
countries I don't know if that's the
right answer but yeah and this for our
case in the food industry is that for
instance the taxonomy of Chinese food in
Syria is completely different and
taxonomy food of Chinese food in China
for instance oh yeah that sounds like a
harder harder problem yeah
you